so the Donald Trump campaign is playing
up that there was a an assassination
attempt against Donald Trump it was
actually a 33 year old guy named Austin
Crites who was beaten up at a trump
event for holding a sign that said
Republicans against Trump he said he was
kicked punched and choked fearing for
his life when the crowd turned on him at
a trump rally in Reno Nevada there were
panicked scenes at the Trump rally
apparently prompted by shouts from at
least one person that someone has a gun
so it seems as though there was a shout
that someone has a gun Austin Crites was
there holding a sign that said something
along the lines of Republicans against
Trump people start fleeing to the back
of the auditorium Secret Service gets
all over Trump and rushes him off the
stage we have video I'm sorry it's not
great for people who are just listening
on the radio stations in the podcast
it's just 20 seconds then we'll continue
with it with the story by the way folks
while we're at it great
yeah
and then a big kerfuffle there so the US
Secret Service has since said there was
no weapon found on the subject that was
detained he had been released what the
Guardian did find however is that the
would-be assassin and I used that term
completely inaccurately
had been bruised up and looked
completely shocked by the entire thing
he said that he quote was in survival
mode and that he knew he could die at
that moment also saying that quote
someone grabbed his testicles and had
his neck in a chokehold
Donald Newton was also at the event he
was interviewed after he said he had
something on his belly I don't know what
it was somebody yelled gun and everyone
jumped on him okay so that's it right no
big deal it was just a mistake
this guy had a sign someone yelled gun
except that the Trump campaign is using
this as a supposed assassination attempt
for publicity minutes after this
happened Trump's campaign social media
director danced Covino posted the
following tweet to his Twitter account
where he said Hillary ran away from rain
today Trump is back on stage minutes
after assassination attempt a guy with
paper is an assassination attempt now
and then at his next event in Denver the
guy introducing Donald Trump his name is
Andre Mohana he was giving the obviously
invitation to kick off the Trump Denver
event referenced and attempted an
attempt at murder take a listen to this
insane you attack him every time
thinking he raises a speech of hate
tonight I think the hate a lot of media
raised against him caused an attempt
against Nevada
yeah Trump supporters pat beat up a guy
with a sign that says Republicans
against Trump the guy paper he's armed
with paper nothing else and then the
Trump campaign starts using terms like
assassination attempt and an attempt at
murder this is the Trump Fantasyland
that they are all living in isn't it and
Donald Trump is one of the most
unpopular presidential candidates of
all time so something like this could
happen I mean look no further than
Robert F Kennedy when he was under an
assassination attempt but the fact that
this was perpetrated by a Republican and
there wasn't even a weapon there I mean
that's just really ridiculous well you
know people have started to say David
look into this guy Austin Crites is he
really a Republican because he shows up
somewhere in the Podesta emails well
that was debunked but his name I guess
might be mentioned in the WikiLeaks in
some WikiLeaks emails that that have
been released it's not really clear the
point is whether he's a secret Democrat
or a Republican or connected to whoever
the guy was armed with nothing more than
paper and it is being promoted used for
PR by the Trump campaign as an
assassination attempt I don't see pat
how it's relevant whether or not this
guy's name shows up on some list right
and they're just trying to chalk up
sympathy for his campaign because as it
looks now he's has a very slim chance to
win I hope you're right a tweet tomorrow
we're not doing it today because we
would just do it over again tomorrow on
election day I've been looking so
closely at all of the polling and data
tomorrow I will be presenting to you my
electoral map prediction we will be
looking at state polls we will be
looking at all of the different analyses
and predictors yeah I I guess generally
I still agree Hillary Clinton is the one
who is best positioned to win the
electoral map particularly makes that a
case for her better than the national
polling which has absolutely tightened
Donald Trump could win tomorrow and we
will be presenting all the data to you
tomorrow if you have any questions
concerns ideas about this story or any
others discuss it with us on our reddit
discussion forum at david pakman.com
slash read it that is re d di t